justin uh let's talk about uh lego
ninjago are you familiar with this
universe were you familiar with it
before you i was not familiar with this
right
i don't know if anyone here is familiar
with that universe but from what someone
called me about getting the job and when
i said great what is it and then i found
out that it's like fight club for 10
year olds like
anyone over the age of 10 does not know
about this thing and then you meet
people's parents and you say like you
know hey if you're like oh my god like
they think it's like you know you just
booked the next star wars or something
no it's it's absolutely i have a 11 year
old son i have a 13 year old daughter
they
like they just love they love incredible
lego ninjago but i'm around other people
and they'll say oh i see you're having
the cast of lego ninja go on yeah
and then i'm like you idiot you know
where have you been under a rock yeah
ninja goes a verb
[Laughter]
uh zach were you familiar with the uh
lego ninjago franchise at all uh not
that much um a 30 year old
32 year old single man so why did you
lie first about your age
i have like very very mild arrested
development where i think i'm just two
years younger than i actually wow you've
got a very small peter pan exactly
i'm not 32 i'm 30.
i think if i knew i think if i were
familiar with the
ninjago franchise that would be a red
flag i think people in my demographic
didn't know shouldn't be that up to
speed about toys
you